Este es el último de los problemas
que nos envía Cortagio en el cual,
como ya te habías dado cuenta,
involucra velocidad, distancia, tiempo,
pero sobretodo
no es un conocimiento
muy duro de matemáticas.
Para resolver estos problemas necesitamos
solamente un poco de lógica y algo de álgebra.
Y bueno,
este problema dice lo siguiente,
Ana y Betty son dos ciclistas
que empiezan
su recorrido simultáneamente,
Ana empieza en el punto "a"
y Betty empieza en el punto "b".
Así que vamos a empezar
a ponerlos por aquí,
aquí va a estar Ana,
Ana empieza en el punto "a"
y por aquí va a estar Betty,
Betty va a empezar
en el punto "b"
y bueno,
ambas viajan a velocidades constantes,
la una hacia la otra,
es decir que Ana va a una cierta velocidad,
que vamos a llamar velocidad subíndice "a",
de Ana,
en dirección hacia Betty
y Betty por su parte
va a ir en dirección hacia Ana,
con una cierta velocidad constante,
vamos a llamarle "v" subíndice "b"
y bueno, después dice
que después de 30 minutos ellas se cruzan,
entonces en un cierto punto,
ellas dos se van a cruzar,
vamos a suponer que es este punto de aquí,
en este punto se va a cruzar
tanto Ana como Betty,
van a pasar una al lado de la otra.
Y lo que sabemos,
es que es después de 30 minutos,
así que si yo me fijo en esta distancia
que tengo de aquí hasta acá,
toda esta distancia,
pues ¿cómo la podríamos obtener?
Pues hay que recordar que la distancia es
exactamente lo mismo
que la velocidad por el tiempo.
Y entonces, utilizando esta fórmula, yo puedo
decir que esta distancia es lo mismo que 30 minutos,
porque en 30 minutos recorrió esta
distancia Ana por la velocidad,
pero Ana tiene una velocidad constante
que habíamos llamado,
"v" subíndice "a",
por lo tanto, 30 por "v" subíndice "a".
Date cuenta que esta es la distancia que ha
recorrido Ana desde que empezó su recorrido
en el punto "a", hasta el punto en donde se
cruzan, hasta este punto de aquí.
Ahora, vamos a pensar lo mismo para Betty,
Betty por su parte ha recorrido esta distancia
que yo tengo aquí...
nos vamos a ir hasta acá
y hasta acá
ha recorrido Betty...
Y Betty, si utilizamos también esta fórmula,
ha recorrido 30 minutos de camino,
porque ambas se cruzan 30 minutos después de que
empezó el recorrido,
pero Betty va a una velocidad
distinta a la que va Ana,
Betty va a una velocidad "v" subíndice "b",
a una velocidad constante.
Por lo tanto, esta distancia de aquí a acá,
la podríamos ver como 30, que es el tiempo,
30 minutos,
por la velocidad a la que va Betty.
Bueno, y después dice,
Ana llega en otros
20 minutos al punto "b",
Ana llega en otros 20 minutos, al punto "b",
¿cómo puedo ver eso?
Pues bueno, esta misma distancia que recorrió
Betty en 30 minutos, Ana la hizo en 20 minutos,
se cruzan en un punto y después de este punto,
Ana sigue pedaleando, pedaleando, pedaleando
hasta llegar al punto "b"
y lo logra hacer
en 20 minutos,
así que esta distancia,
es lo mismo que el tiempo, que son 20 minutos,
por la velocidad,
¿pero de quién estamos hablando?
De Ana, por lo tanto,
20 por la velocidad de Ana.
Muy bien, y justo aquí está la clave de
este problema,
si nosotros entendemos que esta distancia es inmutable, no cambia y por lo tanto esta distancia
es la misma tanto para Betty
como para Ana,
entonces esta distancia
yo la puedo ver como,
30 por la velocidad de Betty
o en su dado caso,
como 20 por la velocidad de Ana.
Después me preguntan,
¿en cuántos minutos... en cuántos minutos
después de que Ana llega al punto "b",
es decir, después de que Ana
llega hasta acá,
llegará Betty al punto "a"?
Es decir, ¿cuánto tiempo después de que
Ana llega a este punto, va a llegar Betty a este punto?
Se cruzan, Ana sigue para acá, Betty sigue
para acá
y bueno, se supone que Ana
va a llegar antes
y entonces Betty va a seguir
pedaleando hasta llegar al punto "a".
¿Cuánto tiempo más, en minutos, va a ser
Betty este recorrido de esta distancia,
es decir,
va a finalizar su recorrido?
Yo lo que quiero saber es,
¿en cuánto tiempo va a ser esta distancia?
Y bueno, para eso, lo primero que quiero que
te fijes, es justo en esta distancia de aquí.
Yo sé que esta distancia es igual para las
dos, por lo tanto yo sé que por una parte,
Betty lo hizo en 30 minutos y lo hizo a una
velocidad de "v" subíndice "b",
a la velocidad a la que iba Betty,
pero por otra parte, esta misma distancia,
la recorrió Ana en 20 minutos
y la recorrió a una velocidad de "v" subíndice "a",
es decir, que "30v" subíndice "b",
es igual a "20v" subíndice "a",
¿y cómo puedo encontrar esta igualdad?
Porque esta distancia es la misma,
esta distancia según mi fórmula,
es lo mismo que 30 por la velocidad a la que iba Betty por una parte,
pero esta misma distancia es igual,
por esta misma fórmula,
a la velocidad a la que iba Ana
por el tiempo, que fueron 20 minutos.
Y bueno, si de aquí yo quiero despejar a
la velocidad de Ana,
entonces voy a obtener
que la velocidad de Ana,
es exactamente igual a 30 entre 20,
por la velocidad de Betty
y bueno, 30 entre 20,
es lo mismo que 3/2,
es decir, que la velocidad de Ana,
la puedo ver como 3/2 de la velocidad de Betty.
¿Y esto de qué me va a servir?
Bueno, ya encontré una forma explícita de
encontrar a la velocidad de Ana
en términos de la velocidad de Betty,
pero yo sé que esta distancia,
Ana la recorrió en 30 minutos
a una velocidad a la que iba, a la velocidad
constante a la que iba Ana, por lo tanto,
si ahora de aquí sustituyo el valor de Ana,
voy a poder encontrar esta misma distancia,
pero ahora expresada en términos de la velocidad
de Betty.
Y bueno, entonces vamos a hacerlo, pero ya
sé que la velocidad de Ana es igual a 3/2
la velocidad de Betty, por lo tanto, en lugar
de la velocidad de Ana, voy a escribir 3/2
de la velocidad de Betty.
¿Y qué me va a quedar?
30, que va a multiplicar a 3/2
por la velocidad
de Betty,
es exactamente igual
que esta distancia que tengo aquí
y bueno, 30 por 3 es 90, entre
2 es 45,
45 por la velocidad de Betty,
es igual a la distancia que hay desde el punto
"a" hasta el punto en donde se cruzan.
Ahora, recuerda que la distancia es igual
a la velocidad por el tiempo,
Betty iba a una velocidad constante "v" subíndice "b"
y entonces esto quiere decir que el tiempo
que le costó a Betty recorrer esta distancia,
son 45 minutos.
Esta distancia en total,
la recorrió Betty en 45 minutos,
¿pero qué me preguntan?
¿en cuántos minutos después de que Ana
llega al punto "b" llegará Betty al punto "a"?
Entonces, se cruzan y 20 minutos después,
Ana llega al punto "b",
ahora, se cruzan
y en 45 minutos después
Betty llega al punto "a",
ahora mi pregunta es,
¿cuánto tiempo hay de diferencia de 20 minutos
a 45 minutos,
que fue el tiempo que se tardó
más Betty para llegar al punto "a"?
Pues vamos a hacerlo,
45 minutos,
a esto le quito 20 minutos,
pues esto es lo mismo que 25 minutos.
Es decir que la respuesta van a ser 25 minutos,
después de que Ana llegó al punto "b",
es  la cantidad de tiempo que se tarda Betty para
llegar al punto "a".
Y ya está y bueno, no olvidemos darle las
gracias a Cortagio por mandarnos este problema.